last time we it was a big lesson about
story time we're introducing all these
read new bits of notation and we have
different ways terms to describe things
one of the key things that we introduced
was this idea your first principles if
you want to find the gradient function
of a function okay we introduced this
idea of rise over run where the rise in
the run get really really really small
okay so if you remember we call that
first principles right we said f dash X
is equal to okay how's that memory what
do we start with we start with the limit
start with a little bit it's hard to
remember
I know grab a sheet on purpose okay then
you've got your fraction which
corresponds to rise over run right rise
over was this is your y2 minus y1 right
which is just like gradient and you got
x2 minus x1 on the bottom okay so the
really useful way to appreciate however
I want to introduce a different way of
saying the same thing because it turns
out to be really important in getting
one of the results that you're gonna use
all the time okay now just before I
start ok this proof is not going to
necessarily be something that you can
test anything like that but you want to
know where it comes from so that as you
use it it's not just like some magic why
God you like it works but I don't know
why so that's why I want you to get this
pattern
so before we said you've got the two
points X and X plus h okay X being some
variable we can move it around okay so
what I want to do here is instead of
working out X at a computer anywhere I
want to work it out at a particular
point and I'm gonna call that C okay so
I would I would read that as f - C
namely the gradient at x equals two so
therefore I'm going to introduce some at
some point C let's put it over here
say if that is C then its height would
be if this is just f of X what looks
like B if I see it good okay so far so
good now I need to introduce some
another point that's gonna travel
towards C so there just like before as
we had H approaches zero we've got a
approaching the gradient and a single
point okay so this time I'm ready to
shoot on that point and because I wanted
to move I'm going to call it X okay so
this corresponds to our X plus h from
the form okay all right so therefore
what would this might be I come across
over here that's X so this is f of X
okay so now what I want to work out this
gradient okay at this particular point
see it's gonna work out in much the same
way except there are going to be mind
the differences up here for instance
there's no H there's no distance here
that's approaching zero instead what I
want is for this point X or rather this
point sorry to move towards the other
point okay so I wanted to sort of home
it's way closer to C so therefore
instead of H equals 0 I'm gonna have X
approaching see that makes sense now
therefore the same way what am i got
over here this rise over run will also
look slightly different
okay I'm gonna have 1 X 2 minus y 1
right
so Y minus y 1 that's my rise okay in
the same way I've got my run over here
which is X C ok so where do we go and
use this example
sorry use this different way of writing
it okay well number one sometimes the
algebra works out easier when you're
doing particular examples and I'll show
you one a second and secondly you
remember that result we looked at before
when we were proving what we so called
the rule
the rule for differentiating tallies
right we said this derivative was equal
to EULA and you bring the power down and
then you reduce the power by one okay no
we sort of proved we didn't really prove
a degree we saw it worked in a lot of
different ways we use the first
principles but that was kind of just
like proving by example okay and proof
by example
doesn't really work that's like saying I
can prove that every student it changes
a girl cuz if hey look he's one he's
another one he's not all my examples
they're all girls right sit proof by
example isn't a very good method right
so if you want to get something more
rigorous we're gonna need something
better then just come here with four or
five examples and so let me give you an
example off how does this um how does it
play out okay let's take one that we
actually know so when we get the result
it'll be something you expect let's take
f of x equals x squared okay so you
already know just by looking at it
because of this rule its derivative will
be 2x so if I want its derivative and
see it will be to see right because X is
equal C okay so how would I use this how
does the algebra work out a little
differently well let's have it go f dash
x equals okay sorry F dash C I want to
add this particular point I'm gonna take
the limit but this time it's X
approaches it okay and then at the top
where do I go I've got x squared minus C
squared or involve X minus C then you
can see all right my goal here is that I
can't simply put in x equals C right
because I've got this denominator
problem so I need to get rid of the
denominator problem what should I do
factorize so I've got difference of
squares yeah okay happy so you can see
it cancels and what you're left with is
this now again need to think about this
okay
now that I've gotten rid of my
derivatives I can say what sorry my de
nom
as X approaches see what happens this
will approach see so I'll have to seat
which is what you're expecting okay now
that's that's fairly trivial in fact if
you look at this example using the
original first principles the first
first principles the algebra is no more
difficult okay so